even Arnold came out against Donald  Trump yeah Arnie female sir yeah Donald  in [ __ ] Annie what is Mary we're  talking about but he was nice to them as  nice a damn occasion for sausage  okay from that denouncing Trump yes they  do the voice I can no longer stand for  someone all of us come back then myself  there's a line people here just crossed  into hi okay you don't grab the [ __ ]  first of all a lot of them would let you  you just have to ask just grabbing it  was he left you like rapping president  and his gnarled are you pro Hillary I  see Hillary is a good woman  misunderstood and sometimes people when  they're around two women they wind up  suiciding themselves the personalities  it makes you humble the governor that  was our governor  [Music]